that's terrible you like what you like
okay
you could date a girl without kids why
on earth would you date a girl with a
kid
because that's that one you're raising
you're putting your time attention and
resources into another man's kid and she
could break it off with you tomorrow you
put all this time attention and
resources and raising someone else's kid
you get nothing you have no rights
you're not going to do anything yeah
because you can say that about the girl
as a single like i mean she doesn't have
a kid as well you put all your time and
resources into that girl for her to
bring you off and cut yeah
child don't know a child's life you're
getting married with no kids
when you when you meet a girl yeah it's
it's not just her attraction is the
whole package
yeah like i would oh my gosh i have
brothers if they brought home a girl
with a kid i would tell them to him to
dump her
immediately
if if off the rip you told me you have a
kid baby daddy's you did it yeah i love
can i like yeah that's madness
tell me
i love that but that's what people tend
to do you know they don't they don't
they don't let you know a few things and
then after a bit when you feel like yeah
it'd be a lot harder
by the way
and there's a lot of people that do it
think about how these stories are on
people that like bring up kids that's
not even theirs bro and they have a
happy family
come on man obviously there's some that
don't yeah but that's with everything
but like why would you want to like take
that extra baggage like that's just
baggage because you have to deal with
the axe yeah you don't look at baggage
if the girls just got like i mean i feel
like the girl just got got it and she's
got it like you know what's interesting
when i'm like talking to a guy and he
tells me he would date a single mom i
like like him less
because i'm like like to me your
discernment is off oh what you think
that they're just picking
more well it's like it's like why would
you if like it's like almost desperate
and i'm not trying to be mean so sorry
but like but like it because i'm like do
you not have any other like are you that
desperate you would date a single mom
how does that show you desperation
because you could like because it's like
you act like there's even if you're
talking to a girl for a month it's only
been a month that's better than raising
someone else's kid for the rest of your
life
and it's one thing like happiness like
i think kids with people with kids
should date each other
i didn't i've i've been in a situation
where dude didn't tell me he had kids i
was out cooked no
oh god
yeah
i blocked i'm
like can we keep dating no and he was he
was rich too like i could have like been
taking care nope nasty cook and i'm and
i'm a girl like
so and i feel like as a guy it's like
worse
yeah but why wouldn't just the vibe is
just right like just you're letting the
kid get in the way of like your
happiness but building building a family
isn't about vibes like it's not about
good vibes and happiness like that's why
that's why marriage is crumbled today
because it's not based on logic it's
based on what feels good in the moment
like oh my god yes
nice like i get it if you want a girl
for the night fine or like a date for a
couple months but i just i feel like men
should have standards and it's really
sad because nowadays like like no
honestly men should have standards and
nowadays like they're ashamed and to
have like not like people yeah that's
very nice do you guys feel like you have
standards
yes
absolutely
100 adam
you
[Music]